das jahr 2015 geht langsam zu ende und
es herrscht krisenstimmung ströme von
flüchtlingen drängen nach europa
einzelne länder machen grenzen dicht
weil sie sich sagen wir schaffen das
nicht und die terroranschläge von paris
lösen zusätzlich angst und hektik aus
was ist los mit uns was mit der welt
wenn krisen aufziehen hilft zuweilen der
nüchterne blick zurück in die geschichte
um zu verstehen wie alles kam man hier
am tisch sitzt deshalb der historiker
philipp blom
vielen ist bekannt als autor des buches
der taumelnde kontinent einem
mitreisenden panorama der zeit
unmittelbar vor dem ersten weltkrieg
heute sieht er uns vor einer zeitenwende
und er sagt wir müssen lernen in einer
neuen welt zu leben
herzlich willkommen herr blum st wir
müssen lernen in einer neuen welt zu
leben weshalb ich glaube das hat
verschiedene gründe einer ist der
klimawandel auf dem wir vielleicht noch
zu sprechen kommen werden das ist sehr
deutlich aber es gibt auch eine neue
politische landschaft glaube ich wir
sind aufgewachsen mit dieser trennung
zwischen rechts und links in der politik
und die wir zunehmend bedeutungslos
stattdessen haben wir jetzt eine neue
trennung die sich zeigt und die glaube
ich immer wichtiger werden wird
die attentäter von paris und von london
und von madrid die haben eine menge
gemeinsam mit leuten mit denen sie sich
wahrscheinlich nicht identifizieren
würden zum beispiel mit der deutschen
päda mit wladimir putin mit
evangelikalen prediger in den usa mit
gerichten saudi arabien und das ist dass
sie alle eine art autoritären traum
träumen und das ist ein traum der die
menschheit den kollektiven sieht in
völkern die historische gemeinschaften
sind irgendwo eine kulturelle essenz
haben
die man bewahren muss das sind träume
die sehen dass die westliche sexualität
etwas entartet es entartet es ist etwas
fürchterliches zügelloses gerade wenn es
um homosexualität geht oder denken sie
ja die abtreibungsdebatte in den
vereinigten staaten
bigler die im allgemeinen finden dass
frauen eher traditionelle rollen spielen
sollten
aber jetzt müssen wir vielleicht doch
noch mal ganz kurz zu den stichworten
zurück das sie haben am angesagt einig
peggy da ähnlich wie terroristen sagen
wir mal vom es ist ein traum der sich
zurück träumt der sich nostalgisch
zurück träumt in eine zeit in der es
noch sicherheiten gegeben hat in einer
zeit in der immer noch wusste wer man
ist in einer zeit in der man noch wusste
wer der feind ist und dieser traum wird
in verschiedenen ausprägungen im moment
auf der ganzen welt geträumt wenn man
hat so ein bisschen das gefühl in europa
wird das was von sozialdemokraten über
jahrzehnte erkämpft wurde inzwischen von
national- konservativen verteidigt das
ist auch glaube ich in der schweiz nicht
anders und hier gibts ich glaube ich
eine neue trennung denn auf der anderen
seite steht eine art liberaler traum und
dieser traum der sich die menschen eher
als individuen der redet er über
freiheit und menschenrechte er
interessiert sich nicht für die
sexualität von menschen und dieser traum
kommt immer mehr in bedrängnis
er kommt auch in bedrängnis weil er sich
selbst nicht nur sehr schlecht verkauft
hat sondern sehr oft auch ad absurdum
geführt hat aber geht peggy gar nicht
ein stück weit gerade für die freiheit
auf die straße
für die freiheit von anderen für die
freiheit so zu bleiben wie man ist
wenn das freiheit ist also ich mein
wissen sie das ist die alte debatte jede
freiheit ist die einschränkung von allen
anderen die freiheit des 1
die einschränkung des anderen aber ich
glaube was wir jetzt mit diesem
flüchtlingsstrom erlebt haben was so ein
bisschen ein böses erwachen für die
europäer war wir haben immer
menschenrechte gepredigt dass sie kennen
diesen ganzen kanon diesen ganzen
katalog von rechten aber implizit war
eigentlich immer die gelten ganz
besonders für uns und jetzt kommen aus
einer nahen region menschen zu uns die
sagen wir wollen das jetzt mit diesem
recht der freiheit vor verfolgung und
ist freiheit der freiheit sein leben
gestalten zu können und der der der
meinungs- und redefreiheit die hätten
wir auch gerne und warum sagen sie
implizit wollten die besonders für uns
weil die allgemeine deklaration der
menschenrechte gilt natürlich für alle
menschen
sie gilt sie geht theoretisch für alle
praktisch ist hat es schon immer große
unterschiede gegeben
ich bin praktisch haben wir die rechte
hier besonders stark für uns
durchgesetzt aber praktisch haben wir
zum beispiel auch immer mit staaten und
regionen praktiziert die diese rechte
mit füßen getreten haben
praktisch profitieren wir in vielerlei
hinsicht von von brüchen dieser dieser
menschenrechte und obwohl das vielleicht
die einzelne konsumenten oder 1 in der
konsument nicht weiß wenn man im
supermarkt oder im kaufhaus steht dann
ist das doch den verantwortlichen sehr
klar was da passiert das heißt es hat
schon immer so ein zwei schienensystem
für menschenrechte gegeben und die
flüchtlinge die jetzt zu uns kommen und
genau diese rechte einzufordern die
haben uns eigentlich darauf hingewiesen
wie fürchterlich unlogisch wird damit
umgehen wie fürchterlich heuchlerisch
wie damit umgehen mit diesen rechten und
wenn jetzt dieser liberale traum den
diskutieren zusammen geht mit den
menschenrechten der verteidigung der
menschenrechte werden sie dann sagen wir
haben uns dazu weit vorgewagt wir waren
hoch mäßig arrogant und dachten wir
könnten diesen liberalen traum wirklich
fertig denken und damit etwas ausrichten
in dieser welt oder sind sie einfach
nicht fertig geworden damit also sind ja
wie soll ich sagen schlicht nicht fähig
gewesen
die menschenrechte wirklich umzusetzen
also sind die menschenrechte das problem
oder unsere unfähigkeit die
menschenrechte umzusetzen schauen sie
natürlich waren wir hochnäsig und
arrogant und sind das natürlich in
vielerlei hinsicht immer noch anderen
menschen und von gegenüber aber dieser
traum ist der schönste traum den die
menschheit je geträumt davon bin ich
überzeugt die tatsache dass jeder mensch
von geburt an etwas wert ist was man
eben nicht wegnehmen kann das jeder
mensch von geburt an rechte hat die man
ihm nicht wegnehmen darf das ist was
ganz wichtig ist aber ich glaube es ist
auch etwas was wir heute leicht
übersehen und wir glauben immer
menschenrechte die hat es schon immer
gegeben die sind stabil die sind
unanfechtbar
aber wenn ich sage das ist ein traum
dann tue ich das aus dem grund weil es
ist eine menschenrechte sind eine
fiktion genauso wie religion eine
fiktion es ist eine geschichte die eine
gesellschaft sich über sich selbst
erzählt und jede gesellschaft braucht so
eine geschichte so ein großes narrativ
und das prägt diese gesellschaft auch
die die werte die in diesen geschichten
stecken die prägen auch wie
gesellschaften handeln wenn sie sich
ansehen was wir seit dem achtzehnten
jahrhundert erreicht haben für europäer
und auch über europa hinaus das ist
großartig das ist das ist wirklich ganz
erstaunlich aber wir dürfen darüber
nicht vergessen es ist eben nur seit dem
18 jahrhundert und sogar voltaire im 18
jahrhundert fand die idee dass jeder
mensch gleich ist völlig lächerlich
man muss sagen die geschichte
weitergesponnen menschenrechte haben
nicht verhindern können dass es
terroranschläge gibt das ist die
kolonialgeschichte gibt aber auch dass
es weit dass sie guantanamo gibt aber
schon recht und wie wenig verhindert
menschenrechte die rhetorik der
menschenrechte wird auch immer wieder
eingesetzt um gerade diese sachen zu
rechtfertigen und ich meine wir haben
natürlich liberté egalité fraternité
aber in diesen im namen dieser sachen
hat es auch schon immer verfolgungen und
morde und unterdrückung gegeben
das heißt das gibt uns natürlich auch
sozusagen eine sehr schwache
verhandlungsposition wenn wir sagen
schaut uns doch unsere wunderbaren
menschenrechte an denn wir haben ja
diese dinge und ideologien in deren
namen dann die unterdrückung in anderen
kontinenten stattgefunden haben auch von
europas exportiert
aber ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig zu
sehen dies ist ein traum diese
menschenrecht und ein traum heißt
erstens um zumindest im
umgangssprachlichen das hat man noch
nicht erreicht und das haben wir noch
nicht
auch unsere eingeben sehr schwer uns in
die nicht gleich es gibt immer noch
große chancen ungleichheit in unseren
eigenen gesellschaften darüber hinaus
ganz zu schweigen aber dieser traum kann
auch wieder verschwinden
es gibt jetzt diese idee von
menschenrechten seit 23 100 jahren das
ist im vergleich zu den jahrtausenden
jahrhundert tausenden dies die
menschheit gegeben hat ein augenblick
und das kann auch wieder verschwinden
ich glaube nach dem was wir im moment
sehen nachdem wie wir sehen was für
einen rechtsruck durch europa geht ist
es überhaupt nicht unmöglich sich
vorzustellen dass in ein zwei
generationen ein kleines autoritäres
hauptsächlich weißes ängstliches europa
eine festung europa neben einem
orthodoxen großreich russland und einem
kalifat daran osten besteht und das
wären dann zumindest reiche oder gebiete
die ähnliche werte teilen würden nämlich
gerade dieser autoritären werte da hatte
diese diese werte von einer essentiellen
kultur so sind wir so ist niemand anders
so sind wir schon immer gewesen und das
ist auch mit nichts anderem kompatibel
das heißt ein fremder muss bitte da
bleiben woher kommt denn der lässt sich
sowieso nicht integrieren in unsere
kultur wir sind etwas anderes und ich
glaube das ist tendenziell ein sehr
gefährlicher traum denn diese
großartigen und wirklich großartigen
errungenschaften die wir seit der
aufklärung
gebracht haben und sie dürfen nicht
vergessen dass das ist nur zehn
generationen her und damals waren die
meisten menschen nichts wert sie sagen
aber auch ja dieser traum der
menschenrechte jetzt so der liberale
traum ist der schönste traum den er je
geträumt haben
warum ist er nicht ansteckend warum
haben sie im moment das gefühl dieser
autoritäre traum nimmt eigentlich
überhand er ist ja an strecke stecken
menschen auf der ganzen welt haben ihm
gewollt und haben auch sind auch sehr
weit gegangen um ihn durchzusetzen es
hat überall bewegungen gegeben die im
namen dieses traums gefordert haben ihre
eigenen regeln zu ändern ihre eigenen
gesellschaften zu ändern und die
tatsache dass es in den meisten ländern
eine allgemeine schulpflicht für kinder
gibt dass man den meisten nennen
zwischen theoretisch zumindest wahrnimmt
dass auch frauen menschen sind etc
das sind konsequenzen dieses traums wenn
eine diktatur eine wahl abhält um sich
zumindest den anstrich an der demokratie
zu geben ist das eine konsequenz dieses
traums und heißt dass zumindest als
theoretischer wert erkennt wird das ist
wichtig oder die wand diese wahrnehmung
ist wichtig aber gleichzeitig ist dieser
traum sozusagen auch ein stück weit eine
zumutung denn freiheit diese freiheit
ist uns gibt die es uns gibt das heißt
auch dass sich menschen sozusagen selbst
konstruieren müssen dass sie nicht mehr
in eine traditionelle identität
hineingeboren werden wo sie wissen ich
bin ein bauer ich bin ein katholik ich
spreche dies ich werde dieses mädchen
von zwei kilometer weiter heiraten
sondern auf einmal ist alles offen
und das ist sehr schwer sich in dieser
welt zurechtzufinden
es wird auch immer schwerer und dazu
kommt noch dass sich in den letzten
jahrzehnten unsere gesellschaften wieder
stark begonnen haben zu spalten
eigentlich in den letzten beiden
jahrzehnten das heißt dass es immer mehr
menschen gibt die an diesen
möglichkeiten die diese freiheit gibt
nicht teilnehmen
können die sehen sich davon auf eine
sehr zynische weise ausgeschlossen
es wird dauernd über menschenrechte und
über freiheit geredet aber sie haben
weder die freiheit ihr leben zu
gestalten noch den beruf zu finden den
sie wollen
das sind ja die zwei punkte das eine ist
die freiheit ist auch anstrengend sie
macht uns müde wir sprechen ja man auch
von der ermüdeten gesellschaft eine
gesellschaftlich dauern darf finden muss
sie alle müssen authentisch sein und
unser wahres ich entfalten
dagegen hat der autoritäre traum wie sie
in den anderen modelle anzubieten die
gemeinschaft die familie vorgegeben
gedreht wurde
das andere ist die frage haben
eigentlich alle an dieser freiheit
partizipieren können
aber wenn wir erst noch mal bei der
ersten frage bleiben folgt daraus nicht
so etwas wie das sie dann sagen müssten
ja diejenigen die den autoritären traum
träumen die sind halt einfach noch nicht
so weit die schaffen das irgendwie nicht
diese freiheit auszuhalten und das wäre
ja wieder finde ich eine relativ
überhebliche haltung ich glaube nicht
dass eine frage ist von dem nicht so
weit sein
es ist eine frage von sich
ausgeschlossen fühlen von vornherein und
es ist auch eine frage der der
frustration mit dieser welt einerseits
von eigentlich für manche menschen für
viele menschen weil sie tatsächlich
objektiv die chancen die in dieser traum
versprochen hat nie gehabt haben
diese diese chancen der freiheit und
andererseits weil es auch eine welt ist
die sich so rapide ändert ich meine
stellen sie sich nur vor was passiert
ist mit der schwulenehe in den letzten
fünf jahren
da es ein verbot wird sein was seit
jahrtausenden bestanden hat was nicht
immer praktiziert wurde aber doch als
gesetz immer bestand hat innerhalb von
wenigen jahren in den meisten westlichen
gesellschaften umgeworfen worden
das ist ein ungeheurer prozess diese
rapide veränderung macht menschen angst
und die therapie der veränderung die
nennen historiker die moderne
und das ist eine dynamik die sich sehr
schwer kontrollieren lässt
das ist in der dynamik von märkten und
wie sie kennen die debatte wie nun
gesellschaften und märkte interagieren
sollen wie stark der gesellschaften
märkte kontrollieren sollen oder dürfen
aber letztendlich ist diese innovation
die wir alle so lieben über die menschen
so endlos sprechen die hat auch sehr
beängstigende züge und ich glaube
deswegen es geht nicht um eine frage
noch indes noch nicht so weit seien
sondern gegenteil es ist auch eine
explizite reaktion darauf weil man schon
so weit ist das kann ich extrem gut
verstehen und spricht der mann auch
davon dass liberale gesellschaften zum
teil wieder so konservative momente
einbauen und spricht wieder über heimat
man betont den wert der familie den wert
von geschichte von traditionen brauchtum
wird plötzlich wieder wichtiger das kann
man ja auch alles verstehen was
gegenbewegung aber viele würden
wahrscheinlich viele jungs zuschauen
würden wahrscheinlich sagen ja moment
mal der es hat doch nicht einfach jetzt
noch eben das bedürfnis wieder ein
bisschen traditioneller zu leben sondern
das ist eine eine gewalttätige
terrorgruppe die hier an die macht will
verstehen sie mich nicht falsch es ist
eine fürchterliche terrorgruppe das ist
keine terrorgruppe hören es ist eine
riesige organisation eine eine
mörderbande aber es ist auch für viele
jugendliche die radikalste
jugendbewegung die sie gekannt haben wie
kann man heute noch radikal sein wenn
sie krank werden wollen dann gibt es
eine bank im internet shop wo sie sich
alle piercings und alle hgs besorgen
können die sie brauchen es gibt nichts
mehr es gibt keine identität mehr die
sozusagen außerhalb des
kommerzialisierten besteht das heißt es
gibt keine wirklich revolutionäre gäste
mehr und der mensch braucht revolution
ist weil junge leute brauchen sicherlich
revolution und die tatsache dass hier
sozusagen authentizität versprochen wird
und dann auch noch gottes wort und dass
man seine eigene rage seine wut gegen
diese gesellschaft kanalisieren kann in
etwas edles und großartiges ich glaube
das scheint das scheint viele junge
menschen sehr anzusprechen
besonders leider viele junge männer
obwohl es ja auch junge frauen gibt die
sich dieser bewegung anschließen und ich
glaube das geht ein stück weit dazu zu
erklären warum das so attraktiv ist ein
bisschen mit sehr veränderten vorzeichen
natürlich aber es ist ein bisschen das
was in den 1930 er jahren der spanische
bürgerkrieg war das ist das wo man eine
radikale geste machen kann eine radikale
geste gegen die eigene gesellschaft und
es ist natürlich auch einen traum und es
gibt auch sehr viele redliche junge
menschen die gewalt ablehnen die
trotzdem sagen dieses kalifat ist das
einzige was uns unsere würde zurückgeben
kann
das heißt meint ich glaube man darf
obwohl man natürlich die bewegung
ablehnen und bekämpfen muss darf man
doch die motivation die menschen dazu
führen sich ist für so etwas anzunähern
die muss man glaube ich sehr ernst denn
der muss man auch versuchen zu verstehen
und ein moment des verstehens besteht ja
vielleicht auch darin dass man sich mal
überlegt was kann eigentlich der
autoritäre traummann bieten außer
vielleicht heimat sicherheiten bericht
wird zugehörigkeit aber ein moment ist
ja auch die konstanz also man glaubt im
autoritären traum an ein leben nach dem
tod an ein paradies an ein ewiges
kalifat was kann der liberale traum sage
ich mir zwar ganz platt an hoffnung
eigentlich bitte ich glaube das ist eine
ganz wichtige frage
diese frage nach der transzendenz jede
gesellschaft braucht eine art von
transzendenz das macht eine ansammlung
von menschen die zufällig am selben ort
leben zu einer gesellschaft das mit
einer gewissen dinge in einer gewissen
weise von denselben dingen träumt für
die für die meisten autoritären träume
ist das eine sehr starke religiöse
trennte helm transzendenz so vladimir
putin hat sich wieder mit der orthodoxen
kirche
verbündet für den liberalen traum war
diese geschichte die sich die
gesellschaft über sich selbst immer
erzählt diese transzendenz tatsächlich
die gültigkeit dieser werte und die
möglichkeit in einer gerechten welt zu
leben nur diese möglichkeit haben wir
inzwischen ein bisschen aufgegeben wir
leben in europäischen gesellschaften die
begriffen haben
wir haben alles was wir bekommen werden
und das wollen wir jetzt behalten unsere
höchste hoffnung ist der erhalt des
status quo
wir wollen nichts abgeben wir wollen mit
niemandem teilen lasst uns bitte in ruhe
wo es geht uns gut
das ist nicht genug das ist ist waren
keine hoffnung das ist keine hoffnung
und ich glaube das ist es das ist auch
deswegen ist ein teil der kritik dieser
dieses autoritären traums am liberalen
durchaus gerechtfertigt wir hoffen auf
nichts mehr und es gäbe so fiel auf dass
man zu hoffen haid unsere gesellschaften
sind längst keine gerechten
gesellschaften unsere wir haben längst
noch die wern zwar menschenrechte
erfunden und reden darüber wie wir haben
sie längst noch nicht durchgesetzt
eine gesellschaft in der jeder mensch
sein oder ihr leben gestalten kann und
diese wunderbare diese wunderbare
formulierung support of happiness in der
unabhängigkeitserklärung der
amerikanischen das heißt ja nicht dass
jeder ein rechter glücklich zu sein
sondern man hat ein recht darauf bis zu
versuchen
das sind wunderbare träume und das ist
die transzendenz sozusagen dieses
fernziel in frieden miteinander leben zu
können
weniger grausam zu sein gewalt
einzudämmen menschen die möglichkeit zu
geben sich zu entfalten
das ist der schönste traum den man
träumen kann aber den haben wir ein
bisschen vergessen wir haben so ein
bisschen vergessen dass wir bürger sind
über die tatsache dass wir konsumenten
sind wir haben so ein bisschen vergessen
dass wir gesellschaften sind über die
tatsache dass wir märkte sind und in
diesen märkten wird es darum dass wenige
leute sehr reich werden weil andere
leute konsumieren
ich verstehe diese negative folie die
positive habe ich glaube ich noch nicht
verstanden ich verstehe dass sie sagen
na ja lasst uns doch träumen davon dass
alle glücklich werden können das ist
sowas gibt wie die wirkliche umsetzung
und erfüllung der menschenrechte das ist
für mich aber noch kein transzendent der
traum also wenn jetzt diejenigen die den
liberalen traum träumen wollen trotzdem
sagen das ist mir nicht genug ich möchte
gerne so was haben die eine
transzendente hoffnung so wie ja sie
damals in ihrem buch die bösen
philosophen der sie die aufklärung neu
aufrollen die figur des dtu eigentlich
in den mittelpunkt stellen und sagen die
die roh hatte genau diese einsicht die
hoffnung auf transzendenz die geht nicht
weg so aufgehört immer wir sein können
dass es ein ganz privater und wichtiger
moment bei den rodeo wollte als junger
mann der jesuit werden hat dann seinen
glauben verloren hat aber nicht seine
nostalgie nach dem glauben können
verloren danach das amoralische system
gibt in dem man eingebettet ist dass es
eine große wahrheit gibt dann der mann
teil hat und so weiter und er hat immer
begriffen diese nostalgie besteht in mir
und er hat es versucht dann mit dieser
nostalgie umzugehen mit diesem glauben
wollen umzugehen indem er sich auf
geschichten verlegt hatte auch
theaterstücke das heißt er hat versucht
ich hätte fast gesagt sich selbst
hinters licht zu führen aber dieses
bedürfnis zu befriedigen ohne sozusagen
in die geschichte hinein zu stürzen und
weder religiös zu werden
stellen sie sich ein theater oder ein
kino vor wenn sie drin sitzen und sie
glauben der geschichte die tat sich da
abspielt nicht zu einem gewissen grad
dann brauchen sie gar nicht erst rein
gehen
dann sehen sie nur die beleuchtung und
die kostüme und
die technischen aspekte des
schauspielens sie müssen also mit den
figuren mit leben sie müssen aber auch
beim verlassen des theaters wissen dass
die schauspiele dass der sie kennen die
berühmte geschichte im wilden westen wo
jemand dann othello erschossen hat aus
der box dem publikum heraus nachdem er
das thema erwirkt hat weil er halt das
differenzieren zwischen schauspiel und
realität nicht ganz so gut
ja also wir dürfen nicht dort hell und
schießen wir müssen wissen wir brauchen
diese teilnahme an etwas anderem
aber wir müssen nach verlassen auch das
des theaters auch wieder wissen jetzt
sind wir wieder einander anderen welt
und die option wieder wenig gewiss zu
werden
für mich persönlich ist das keine option
ich glaube dass es eine fiktion die
wesentlich mehr schaden angerichtet hat
als sie gutes gebracht hat ich glaube
auch wir haben inzwischen eine bessere
weise gefunden die welt zu verstehen
durch die wissenschaftlichkeit aber ich
glaube auch wir haben es ist uns allen
ein bedürfnis etwas zu einem sinn zu
haben einen ein muster zu haben mit dem
nachdem wir die welt lesen können und
mit diesem bedürfnis müssen wir
intelligent umgehen lernen aber das ist
wie sie richtig sagen das befriedigt
unser bedürfnis nach dieser großen
transzendenz nicht wir müssen also mit
einer transzendenz leben von der wir
wissen dass sie eigentlich ein
schattenspiel ist auf der anderen seite
ist die möglichkeit eine gerechtere welt
zu schaffen
eine reale möglichkeit das ist kein
schatten spielen
sie können zwar sagen diese
gerechtigkeit über die sie reden die
freiheit die menschenrechte das sind
doch bloß ideen das sind doch bloß
fiktionen und das reicht den menschen
nicht aber ich glaube gleichzeitig wenn
sie sehen was für potenziale das
entfesselt hat in den gesellschaften in
denen ist das gegeben hat was für
potenzielle zumuten denn es ist ein
großartiger traum und wir müssen uns
irgendwann abfinden mit der tatsache
dass es diese andere transzendenz nicht
gibt dass das eine geschichte war die
sich menschen lange erzählt haben und
wir haben zu unserem großen bedauern
festgestellt diese geschichte ist leider
nicht wahr
sie haben vorhin von nostalgie
gesprochen und dann musste ich daran
denken was ich an mama tatsächlich so
ist dass gerade viel mehr beispielsweise
dazu dienen uns geschichten wieder zu
erzählen und am samstag nach den
terror-anschlägen in paris haben viele
menschen rund um die welt einen
ausschnitt aus dem film casablanca ins
internet gestellt und er wurde vielfach
fast wie radon eingeteilt hat sich
verbreitet und in diesem ausschnitt
sieht man wie die nazis ihre hymne
anstimmen und danach in diesem café in
casablanca die anderen beginnen die
master es dagegen anzusingen und
feiertagen unfertig ssten sind für mich
genau lassen sie uns lassen sie uns den
ausschnitt zusammen anschauen
[Musik]
streckt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine ihrer lieblingsszenen auch aus dem
sehen sie morgen den schienen ja sehr
ich ja ich bin immer etwas gerührt wenn
ich diese szene sehen
das interessante ist dieser film hat
eigentlich sozusagen hollywood ist
berühmt berüchtigt dafür dass alles
künstlich ist und nichts war ist dieser
film wurde mit flüchtlingen gemacht die
leute die in dem film sind in rick's
café die spielen sich eigentlich selber
mit der ironischen ausnahme von mario
strasser die sie da gesehen haben dem
ober nazi der ein österreicher war der
vor den nazis geflohen ist
sonst aber die flüchtlinge sprechen ihre
akzente weil sie tatsächlich aus diesen
ländern geflohen sind und ziemlich ein
großartiges projekt ein großartiges
projekt aber ich meine auch so ein
moment wo man das gefühl hat diese
beiden träume die die treffen
aufeinander
die wacht am rhein und die macht sich
als wenn wir jetzt weiter gehen von
diesem ausschnitt aus auf die
flüchtlingsströme zu sprechen kommen das
ist ja schon eines der krisen momente
wenn ihr jetzt aufs jahr 2015 schon so
ein bisschen zurückblicken und einige
zeitungen haben getitelt und mache das
auch in mit den hörer den talkshows
damit eine neue völkerwanderung ist im
gang
stimmt das aus historischer sicht naja
ich bin kein motiv ist aber ich glaube
die völkerwanderung war etwas besonders
bevor es moderne staaten gab
auch bevor es völker im sinne des 19
jahrhunderts gab aber an dass sich
bevölkerung also dass wir würden das
heute vielleicht eine migrationsbewegung
nennen aber das ist letztendlich nicht
so wahnsinnig anders
ja natürlich ist das so und ich glaube
das ist das was europa verändern wird
und auch verändern muss und da brauchen
wir den mut und die fantasie dass auch
aufzunehmen und zu tun
und das liegt nicht nur an den
flüchtlingen das liegt unter anderem
auch daran dass wir seit 100 jahren zu
wenig kinder bekommen unsere bevölkerung
hofen zum teil sehr drastisch unsere
bevölkerung sind überaltert wir brauchen
verzweifelt mehr junge menschen in
unseren gesellschaften und werden wir
sie nicht selber produzieren dann müssen
sie vom woanders kommen und das heißt
sie werden anders sein
warum können wir nicht einfach weniger
sein warum können wir nicht einfach
weniger sein weil die tatsache dass wenn
wir werden sie sich überlegen dass in
den nächsten 50 jahren dann nur noch die
hälfte von der menschen in deutschland
leben würden von heute wenn sie sich
vorstellen was das heißt für die
wirtschaftliche gesundheit eines landes
wenn sie sich vorstellen was das heißt
für den politischen einfluss eines
landes und dieser politische einfluss
ist wichtig denn ich habe vorhin gesagt
unsere werte sind eine fiktion wie die
religion das ist so aber es gibt andere
gesellschaften mit anderen fiktionen
china hat ohne die idee von
menschenrechten besonders zu
thematisieren und ohne die idee von
persönlicher freiheit zu thematisieren
eine sehr erfolgreiche gesellschaft
geschaffen 100 millionen von menschen
aus der armut befreit
das heißt diese den liberalen traum zu
träumen ja das heißt aber diese
wertvorstellungen die konfrontieren sich
auch immer wieder und wenn wir wollen
dass die werte der europäischen
aufklärung die doch immerhin blühende
gesellschaften hier geschafft da
geschaffen haben dass die nicht völlig
verschwinden dann brauchen wir eine
gewisse politische präsenz
dann brauchen wir auch die
wirtschaftsleistung auf der so eine
präsenz er beruht und wenn wir uns damit
abfinden wir sind ein alternder weißer
schrumpfender kontinent dann ist es
glaube ich sehr arm bestellt um diese
gesellschaft wenn es uns nur noch darum
geht den reichtum den wir haben nicht
weg zu geben nicht zu teilen
unsere hohen lebensstandard
nicht zu kompromittieren ich glaube dann
haben wir alles verloren wovon wir
vorhin geträumt haben jetzt ist ja diese
unglaubliche willkommenskultur
entstanden also einerseits natürlich das
reine diktum von angela merkel grenzen
auf willkommenskultur anders als eine
beispiellose solidarität von menschen
die sich freiwillig engagieren
in unglaublich viel hilfsbereitschaft
sich jetzt zeigen gleichzeitig viel
kritik an dieser sogenannten
willkommenskultur
ist das die richtige reaktion ihrer
meinung nach und sagen mir jetzt mal den
liberalen traum weiter zu träumen und
darüber in diesem liberalen traum zu
retten
ich würde sagen ja aber ich unterschätze
keineswegs was für konflikte ist damit
in der zukunft sicherlich auch geben
wird diese liberale diese diese
willkommenskultur die sie erwähnen hat
unglaubliches zustande gebracht in sehr
kurzer zeit und sie hat es uns
ermöglicht sehr viele menschen in unsere
gesellschaften zu beginnen zu
integrieren es wird ein sehr langer
prozess sein und auch ein
konfliktgeladenen prozess ich glaube
nicht
ich meine die alternative wäre mauern um
europa die alternative wären dass
menschen dann anders nach europa kommen
wenn sie so sie sind kommen sie kommen
sowieso oder druck ist zu stark es gibt
zu viele verzweifelte armen menschen zu
viele kriege und wenn die
klimaveränderung erstmal wirklich
anfängt unsere leben zu bestimmen wird
es noch viel mehr davon geben
durch steigende ozeane durch
veränderungen von wetter mustern usw
und ich glaube da ist es sehr wichtig
dass wir jetzt sehen diese veränderungen
werden stadt will
dafür haben wir in einer gewissen weise
eine verantwortung weil wir die das
carbon was sich über jahrmillionen in
der erde angesammelt hat innerhalb von
200 jahren dann wieder in die atmosphäre
gepustet haben aber das ist natürlich
keine individuelle verantwortung niemand
hat das besonders böswillig getan aber
es ist nun mal eine tatsache dass diese
veränderung sich wohl ziehen wird und
dass sich dadurch auch die europäischen
gesellschaften grundsätzlich ändern
werden ich klappe das ist auch eine
riesige chance
eine tatsache die tatsache dass diese
gesellschaften diverser werden können
wir waren lange weiß und christlich wir
waren auch nicht immer weiß und
christliche sind weiß seit ungefähr
50.000 jahren wir sind christlich seit
2000 jahren
das ist nicht so wahnsinnig lang jetzt
wird es eine neue phase geben eine phase
in der diese gesellschaften
pluralistischer werden und es ist völlig
unzweifelhaft dass das menschen angst
macht und das ist auch völlig
unzweifelhaft dass wir nicht wissen wo
das hingeht und dass wir nicht wissen
wie sich das ausspielen wird aber ich
glaube nicht dass es eine wirkliche
andere möglichkeit geht mit dieser
historischen konstellation umzugehen
wir können veränderungen gestalten
wie können sie zu einem gewissen grad
auch steuern
wir können sie nicht verhindern ich
spüre extrem stark jetzt spricht der
historiker und ich kann das sehr gut
nachvollziehen aber ein bisschen kriege
ich dann immer den eindruck dass ich so
ein bisschen wie wenn man einen
astrophysiker spricht der einem sagt ja
hören sie regen sie sich nicht so aus
ein paar milliarden jahre nicht die
sonne sowie so ausgebrannt und dann ist
hier sowieso sensi feuer
gleichzeitig gibt ja auch den
politischen blick oder sagen wir mal
ganz einfach den blick von uns allen die
wir in diesen ländern leben und sie
haben die angst erwähnt menschen die
sagen ich möchte aber nicht dass sich
das verändert ich möchte aber dass man
hier noch genauso krippenspiele hatten
weihnachten feiert und das die schule
noch so sind dass man noch meine sprache
spricht und so weiter nehmen sagt was
gegenspieler und weihnachten dann sagen
sie mal wie sie hier wie sie denken dass
diese integration funktionieren kann ist
dass das zauberwort integration weil sie
haben ja gleichzeitig auch
gesagt wir müssen ja nicht unbedingt
weiß bleiben die müssen ja nicht
unbedingt christlichen werden ich habe
die die menschheit die menschheit
die menschheit wird nicht weiß bleiben
aber das ist jetzt der historiker
spricht und ich denke jetzt in den
nächsten 100 paar hundert jahre
die menschheit wird nicht weiß bleiben
das ist halte ich für keine besondere
katastrophe aber wenn sie jetzt sagen
integration wir haben diese debatte
gehabt diese seltsame debatte um den
multikulturalismus und der war ich
glaube an eine aus guten beweggründen
missverstandene initiative denn sie hat
menschen letztendlich sozusagen in
kulturelle gruppen eingeteilt und sagte
du bist ein pakistanischer muslim obwohl
dieser mensch der vielleicht von
pakistanischen eltern kommt nie seinen
glauben praktiziert hat und völlig
anders sozialisiert ist und ein ganz
anderes leben lebt das heißt dieses
apache ali sieren von gemeinschaften die
dann auch geld vom staat kriegen und
damit politik beginnen zu machen
das hat glaube ich die gesellschaft eher
gespalten als dass es ihr geholfen hat
ich glaube dass ich mein traditionelle
sozusagen immigranten migrations
gesellschaft und wie zum beispiel die
usa
die machen es hier vor wie es anders
gehen könnte
sie haben ein großes problem mit der
integration immer noch oder mit den
menschenrechten der unfreiwilligen
migranten in die vereinigten staaten
nämlich der nachfahren der sklaven aber
andere populationen haben sie sehr
erfolgreich integriert indem sie
einerseits vielleicht so eine art
amerikanischen traum geschaffen haben
mit dem sie auch große probleme haben
weil der im großen und ganzen
ausgeträumt ist
aber indem sie andererseits gesagt haben
wir müssen regeln haben auf die wir uns
alle einigen die müssen auch respektiert
werden über die wird auch nicht
diskutiert die gleichheit und frauen und
männern zum beispiel aber andere dinge
können menschen in ihren eigenen leben
gestalten wie sie möchten und wenn sie
ist das ist dann die budgets berühmte
beispiele ich meine wenn jetzt mehr
interessante restaurants entstehen ist
das sehr schön und das ist aber auch
natürlich auf eine fatale weise ein
mittel flossen traum oder ein
mittelklassen interesse denn die meisten
leute gehen nicht in mehr interessante
restaurants restaurants die meisten
leute sehen den migranten hauptsächlich
als eine bedrohung ihrer eigenen
arbeitsplätze ihre eigenen lebensweise
ihres eigenen lebensraumes damit sie
sagen uns die sozialwissenschaften haben
sie nicht recht denn wo immer ist große
migrantengruppen gibt zahlen sie mehr
steuern als die sozialleistungen vom
staat nehmen das mit den jobs ist auch
nicht so dass die citi citi jobs dem den
leuten wegnehmen die da sind wir haben
jetzt schon arbeitslos aber die haben
wir letztendlich leider weil unsere
ökonomien diese menschen nicht mehr
brauchen wir brauchen inzwischen gut
ausgebildete menschen menschen die nicht
viel ausbildung haben die finden nichts
mehr
in diesen in unseren ökonomen das ist
vielleicht tragisch es wird aber nur
mehr werden
und das könnte sich möglicherweise durch
die flüchtlinge verstärken da es ja
einen streit im gang unter ökonomen die
einen sagen es wird eine heerschar gehen
von arbeitslosen andere sorgen
die flüchtlinge werden dafür sorgen dass
wir ein neues wirtschaftswunder erleben
da gibt es glaube ich eine gewisse
streitigkeit aber ich würde gerne noch
die frage stellen wie positiv können wir
auf die flüchtlingsströme gucken ich
meine das eine ist ja eine schlicht
sagen wir mal ethische frage haben wir
nicht sowieso eine pflicht die grenzen
zu öffnen
diese menschen hier willkommen zu heißen
es sind viele menschen kriegsflüchtlinge
da geht sozusagen einfach an moralischen
imperativ dass ich die eine schiene die
andere schiene ist bringt uns das
wirklich etwas und da geht's ja nicht
jetzt nur peggy der anhänger die sagen
wollen wir alles nicht sondern es gibt
auch intellektuelle die waren es gibt
den historiker jurowski der sagt angela
merkel machte ein wahnsinns projekt sie
ist dafür zu kritisieren und so
verantwortung zu ziehen weil unsere
gesellschaft wird
brechen aber es gibt auch so jemanden
wie rüdiger safranski den philosophen
der hat in der nzz am sonntag in einem
interview gesagt wir lügen uns um die
tatsache herum dass europa eine festung
sein muss schließlich haben sie auch
wirklich etwas zu verteidigen
na ja wissen sie es ist das ist jetzt
ein bisschen komplex denn einerseits wie
sie sagen das eigene interesse und die
moral
wir haben etwas zu verteidigen und
natürlich wir haben für das was wir
besitzen und auch für die sozialen
errungenschaften die wir haben hart
gearbeitet aber das ist so ein bisschen
wie wenn ein junge aus reichem hause
sich wirklich bemüht
und dann sagt ich habe alles aus eigener
kraft getan
wir haben wahnsinnig viel geerbt wir
hatten einen gigantischen start vorteil
und wir leben immer noch von der
ausbeutung anderer länder und menschen
in von menschen in anderen ländern
ich werde die beispiele muss ich ihn
nicht zitieren die billigen t shirts du
irgendwo genäht werden unsere computer
die von kindern in westafrika
auseinander genommen werden um nach
schwermetallen oder kostbar metallen zu
suchen die dadurch krank werden
der smog in china der jetzt herrscht da
herrscht weil sie unsere billigen
konsumgüter herstellen
das heißt vier leben natürlich davon wir
haben in einer gewissen weise zwar
unsere gesellschaft enorm verbessert
aber auch zum teil in dem wir das elend
das wir im neunzehnten jahrhundert hier
hatten exportiert haben in andere
kontinente vom kolonialismus ganz zu
schweigen
das heißt natürlich besteht er eine
gewisse moralische verantwortung aber
natürlich ist die frage auch legitim was
haben wir da ran ich glaube das habe ich
versucht zu erzielen was wir daran haben
wir leben in alternden gesellschaften in
gesellschaften die es auch ein bisschen
verlernt haben einen gemeinsamen
um zu haben denn wohlstands erhaltung
ist kein gemeinsamer traum und die frage
ist natürlich wie intelligent wie
fantasievoll gehen wir mit diesen
migranten um eines und andererseits
natürlich auch was haben die uns
anzubieten
das ist eine frage die sich nur sehr
schwer beantworten lässt im moment wie
brauchen sie davon bin ich überzeugt wir
brauchen junge menschen
wir brauchen junge menschen die bereit
sind gut ausgebildet in unsere an
unseren gesellschaften teilzunehmen
andererseits ist es zweifellos dass da
viele menschen rein kommen die antik mit
antisemitismus umgeben waren da wo sie
herkamen
die für die frauen natürlich nicht
denselben wert habe für die homosexuelle
überhaupt etwas fürchterlich ist in das
heißt es wird da auch viel
überzeugungsarbeit geben wobei sich auf
der anderen seite auch zitiert haben mit
peggy da zb dass es diesen autoritären
traum ja auch in europäischen und
herrschaften gibt und wir selber auch
wieder uns erfinden müssen
und da finde ich gerade interessant dass
eine große initiative in deutschland in
dieser woche aus der taufe gehoben ist
unter dem titel die offene gesellschaft
werden an schauspielhäuser nimmt ihr
euch in den schulen in unternehmen
werden debatten geführt mit der
bevölkerung deutschlands
das in einem auf die persönlichkeiten
beteiligt harald welzer außen nein an
richard david precht daniel cohn bendit
personen die sich gratis dahin setzen
und mit den leuten diskutieren was für
einer gesellschaft wollen wir sein
das finde ich ein extrem das ist genau
der ansporn der vielleicht europa wieder
zum leben erwachen lassen kann man das
für eine gesellschaft wollen wir
eigentlich sagen genau aber da
interessiert mich auch kann man sich
denn eine identität herbeireden oder ist
das erde wo ich weiß nicht verdeckt
zwischen uns liegen muss man was die
aufdecken oder wie entsteht in eine
gemeinsame identität
naja durch reden dass durch reden von
früher kindheit an
völlig durch geschichten eine identität
ist die geschichte die wir uns über uns
selbst erzählt daraus entsteht die man
kann sie nicht analysieren und dann
sagen das ist ein bisschen weniger wird
dieses ein bisschen besser jetzt machen
wir es mal so es ist nicht rational ist
übrigens noch was was die doro
verstanden hatte und das ist glaube ich
was sehr wichtig ist man kann menschen
nur rational überzeugen wenn man bereits
sehr viel mit ihm teilt wenn man bereits
sehr viele ausgangsvoraussetzungen sehr
viele aktionen gemeinsam hat dann kann
man sagen da ist die argumentation
fehler gemacht das müsste man vielleicht
anders sehen
menschen die sozusagen vom gefühl her
ganz anders die welt sehen die kann man
nur versuchen über das gefühl zutritt zu
erreichen die kann man nur versuchen zu
bewegen und das haben wir ja auch
gesehen es gibt die größten proteste
gegen flüchtlinge da wo am wenigsten
flüchtlingen sind menschen die gelernt
haben mit menschen anderer kulturen
gemeinsam eine neue kultur zu schaffen
die haben diese berührungsängste nicht
die haben auch gelernt es ist nicht so
katastrophal
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle noch
einmal mit ihnen gemeinsam etwas
anschauen und zwar genau genau dieses
moment hat dazu geführt dass ich mich
erinnert habe an eine kinderserie die
hieß pepino jahr 1983 die wurde
koproduziert von der srg zdf orf und die
idee dahinter war damals dass man kinder
aber auch erwachsene sensibilisiert für
das schicksal italienischer einwanderer
etwas was wir ja fast schon vergessen
haben weil sie mit den italienern ja
mittlerweile sind ganz
selbstverständlich zusammenleben schauen
wir uns einen ausschnitt barren aus
peppino
das ist die pepino komfort jetzt da
costa und vítor in südafrika
was ist platz für neue schüler
kann freiwilligen gut dann zieht sie mit
dem sony
vielmehr können identitäten schaffen sie
können aber auch abgrenzungen bewirken
was halten sie von solchen projekten und
gibt entsprechende beispiele heute da
dürfen sie mich nicht fragen ich bin
wirklich kein experte für
kinderprogramme aber ich sage ihnen eins
ich gucke gerne die sendung mit der maus
und da ist der christoph die figur die
da durch die sendung führt geht im
moment regelmäßig in einem
flüchtlingslager in deutschland und
trägt ein syrisches mädchen und
tatsächlich habe ich das gefühl das ist
eine ähnliche geschichte man versucht
begegnung zu schaffen an das persönliche
schicksale zu vermitteln
das ist wahnsinnig wichtig und natürlich
auch immer riskant weil es immer etwas
paternalistisches wirkt aber sicherlich
gerade für kinder ist glaube ich ganz
besonders wichtig dass die es ist auch
eine wissen migration ist immer eine
generationenfrage
und es geht immer letztendlich um drei
generationen
die zweite ist immer die problematische
die drei die zwischen allen stühlen
sitzt
die erste ist die idee von ganz
bescheidenen anfängen kommt das sind die
berühmten wirtschaftsflüchtlinge bei dir
heute alle menschen schimpfen ich
begreife was schlimm ist ein
wirtschaftsflüchtlingen das deutsche
wirtschaftswunder der nachkriegszeit ist
das produkt von wirtschaftsflüchtlingen
oder von wirtschaftsmigranten die im
ruhrgebiet und in anderen
industriegebieten dieses
wirtschaftswunder geschaffen haben
natürlich ist es wichtig dass sich
gesellschaften selbst bestimmen aber es
ist genauso wichtig dass diese
gesellschaften offene gesellschaften
bleiben
ich glaube eine festung europa ist eine
ist eine fürchterliche idee und es ist
so ein bisschen dann die tatsache dass
wir letztendlich ein kontinent werden
der der sehr hübsch ist weil viele alte
gebäude herum stehen viele kunstwerke
drin senden wir können uns dann in
nationaltracht kleiden und den touristen
tickets verkaufen nach europa denn
dieses europa ist dann ein europa das
ganz der vergangenheit und dem erhalt
gewidmet ist
wir sind ja auch überall sprießen neue
museen aus dem boden das konservieren
ist das wichtigste geworden was wir tun
können
ich glaube das ist eine sehr ist eine
sehr gefährliche mentalität eigentlich
wenn man gar nicht mehr in die zukunft
oder nur notgedrungen und gegen den
eigenen willen in die zukunft blickt wie
jetzt bei dem klimagipfel wo es ja nicht
darum geht erstaunliche wunderbare neue
dinge zu schaffen durch eine grüne
revolution sondern im angesichts der
gähnenden katastrophe doch noch
vielleicht etwas nachzubessern und es
wird nichts großartiges passieren auf
diesem klima gibt sie haben das
ruhrgebiet erwähnt auch pepino ist ein
beispiel was sind ein gleiche kategorie
ähnliche kategorie gehört sie natürlich
zeiten gewesen in denen man ganz bewusst
man kann sagen wirtschaftsflüchtlinge
wir haben vom saisonniers ausgesprochen
menschen angezogen hat man brauchte
diese leute um ein wirtschaftswunder
voranzubringen um die industrialisierung
voranzubringen
heute ist es natürlich und das ist
wahrscheinlich doch der große auch zu
noch ich mal was man darf nicht
missverstehen die arbeitslosen die es
gibt sind arbeitslos weil sie nicht
qualifiziert genug sind für unseren
arbeitsmarkt und die werden auch
arbeitslos bleiben egal wo sie herkommen
wir brauchen unsere gesellschaft unsere
unsere wirtschaft braucht höher
qualifizierte menschen und da ist es
auch egal wurde hier und da meinen ja
viele starten wir können das prima regel
mit einwanderung wir suchen uns die gut
qualifizierten arbeitskräfte den rest
wollen wir nicht und bekommt
wahrscheinlich schon so im moment das
würden sie wahrscheinlich aus
europäischen dunkel bezeichnen müssen
sie das jede einwanderungsgesellschaft
versucht die menschen erinnern zu lassen
die die sie für nützlich hält und das
ist glaube ich völlig legitim
es gibt auch einen großen unterschied
aber es gibt einen großen unterschied
zwischen einwanderung und flucht
die menschen die jetzt nach europa
gekommen sind sind gekommen weil ihr
leben unmittelbaren gefahr
weil sie flüchten mussten weil nicht nur
ihr job weg war und vielleicht ihre
wohnung sondern auch ihre straße und
ihre stadt und die ganze welt in der sie
gelebt haben und ich glaube da muss man
dann diesem end das muss man anders
anders sehen und danach vielleicht sehen
wir sind in einem historischen moment wo
sich sachen sehr stark ändern werden
das wird problematisch sein das wird uns
herausfordern
aber aus dieser herausforderung heraus
können wir auch vielleicht unser projekt
neu definieren und unser projekt neu
entdecken dass wir so ein bisschen
vergessen haben kulturelle sprünge
kulturelle blüten sind immer durch durch
migration entstanden
ob sie ich bin daher es gibt zum
beispiel die hugenotten im 16 und 17
jahrhundert die preußen geholfen haben
groß zu machen
ein land das nichts hat außer sand und
kartoffeln es gehabt es gab natürlich
die juden am späten neunzehnten anfang
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts die gewandert
sind aus den gerade aus dem pass dem
gebiet wo sie wohnen mussten oft also in
galizien und in den russischen
territorien der heutigen ukraine usw
die natürlich mit denselben argumenten
abgelehnt wurden mit denen heute die
flüchtlinge abgelehnt worden aber das
was ist ein großartiger kultur durch
diese durch diese begegnung gegeben hat
auch unfreiwillige begegnung davon
zehren wir heute noch
migration ist ganz schlüssel haft dabei
so etwas entstehen zu lassen
sie haben nicht vom anfang erwähnt ein
buch geschrieben das heißt der taumelnde
kontinent wurde im ganz ganz breit
rezipiert ein fulminantes werk in dem
sie die zeit beschreibung vor dem ersten
weltkrieg 1900 bis 19 14 tagen
eigentlich grundstimmung damals war
angst und sie sagten auch anfangs des
jahres bewegung
beides gehöre stimmt aber dann immer bei
der
das war eine stimmung und sie sagen es
gibt große parallelen zu heute hat sich
für sie jetzt im laufe des jahres etwas
an diesem bild geändert oder hat sich
das sogar zu gespräche intensiviert die
angst das ist für mich dieser dieser
autoritäre reaktionäre traum das ist
eine reaktion auf diese angst ich will
diese moderne welt nicht diese welt die
pluralis diese welt die frei ist diese
welt in der jeder mensch ein recht hat
ich habe mehr rechte
das ist ein rückzug aus dieser aus
dieser verwirrenden und sich ständig
verändernden welt aber sie sehen
gleichzeitig dass debatten sie sehr
parallel sind wenn sie sich nur mal
ansehen in der viktorianischen zeit am
mitte ende 19 jahrhundert hat man die
slumbewohner der großen europäischen
städte angesehen als eine andere rasse
mensch die wissenschaftler und sozial
beobachter und schriftsteller sind dahin
gekommen und haben gesagt diese menschen
die sind die sind verdreckt und dumm und
krank die sind nicht wie wir die können
wir nicht integrieren in unsere
gesellschaft die sind anders die sind
nicht reformierbar
das humanste was wir machen können ist
dafür zu sorgen dass die weniger kinder
kriegen oder gar keine und langsam
aussterben und dass wir die gesunde die
gesunde bevölkerung fördern das bad die
eugenik die dann bei hitler natürlich
ein fürchterlicher weise ausgeartet bis
heute nennen wir das nicht mehr rasse
das ist nach hitler nicht mehr möglich
heute nennen wir das kultur und sagen
sehr höflich diese menschen haben nicht
unsere kultur
deswegen sind sie nicht integrierbar
denn unsere kulturen deren kultur die
haben zu wenig gemeinsam
wir können nur auf abstand mit denen
leben aber unsere kulturen können sich
wir sind ja auch kulturell ist ist
rassistisch wird aber erst wieder
dasselbe kultur so eine art kampfbegriff
geworden dadurch ja alle kulturen
entwickeln sich kulturen sind diese
geschichten die wir uns selbst erzählen
und diese geschichten ändern sich nur
wir müssen uns überlegen welche
geschichten uns wirklich wichtig sind
welche geschichten wir an unsere kinder
weitergeben wollen erstmal müssen wir
versuchen unseren kindern und vor allem
deren kindern keinen planeten
weiterzugeben der fünf grad wärmer
geworden ist denn dann wird dann nicht
mehr einfach bewohnbar sein
aber zum anderen müssen wir überlegen
was wollen wir denen eigentlich an
hoffnungen träumen weiter geben und
diese kulturen und diese geschichten die
ändern sich sehen sie sich nur an wie
radikal sich deutschland geändert hat
zwischen sagen wir 1930 und 1950 eine
martialische chauvinistische
nationalistische kultur ist in jeder
weise wirklich völlig anders geworden
gut dazwischen lag eine katastrophe aber
kulturen na hat live ändern sich und wir
haben jetzt die historische chance einer
neuen narrativ oder an der veränderung
des gesichtes unserer geschichte
mitzuwirken dass er jetzt ein
schlusswort lassen sie mich doch noch
eine ganz persönliche frage nach
schieben sie leben in wien
mir geht es im moment so es ist advent
die welt wird festlich unserem geben
wird festlich man wird gelockt mit
vielen kaufangebot sind man kriegt
diesen eindruck von diesem konsumismus
in diesen wochen fast nicht weg haben
sie manchmal auch so ein bisschen ein
schäbiges gefühle 60 millionen
flüchtlinge weltweit sie haben den
klimawandel erwähnt diese krisenstimmung
kennen sie dieses gefühl ich lebe in
wien in einem migrantenviertel wo ich
diese menschen täglich sehe und ich
meinen unser wir haben inzwischen unsere
identität so stark auf konsum
es kommt darauf an was für eine marke
man trägt dann ist man ein anderer
mensch
man definiert sich selbst über marken
und konsum ist für uns eine integraler
bestandteil unseres selbst geworden auch
das ist übrigens historisch was sehr
neues und natürlich wenn man sich
überlegt ich konsumiere konsumiere hier
verpflichtet und überlege mir mein gott
was soll ich diesen menschen schenken
der hat doch schon alles sagen was muss
ich ihm geben und man weiß andere leute
haben nicht genug zu essen damit wir
nicht das schon ein problem ja klar das
machen sie damit
was mache ich damit ich mache die
kleinen trivialen dinge die menschen tun
ich spende hier ich spende da ich
versuche mich ich versuche nicht ganz so
realistisch zu sein wie ich es sonst
täter aber ich bin natürlich als mensch
der viel mehr konsumiert also zurück
gibt der viel mehr energie konsumiert
die nicht mehr
wieder bringt er ist auch ein teil des
problems das sind wir alle im westen
ich danke ihnen für dieses gespräch
danke um eine zeitenwende geht es auch
jetzt gleich in der sternstunde kunst
aber heute zeigen die ihnen eine
sechsteilige filmserie zur geburt der
moderne
wir starten in paris und 1900 wo sich
maler und literaten aus ganz europa
begegnen unter ihnen auch pablo picasso
bleiben sie also dran und kommen sie mit
auf eine reise in die welt der pariser
buemi an
ich danke ihnen fürs interessenten
wünsche ihnen für morgen einen guten
start in eine neue woche
[Musik]